so
hey
what's goodie
hello everyone what's goodie
hello everyone what's goody
what's popping everyone welcome to our
weekly q a
i have my
npr voice on i literally just woke up
from a nap for those of you that joined
our right tent club this morning
i got to
see me in an anonymous hotel
um
meeting room
doing right ten from the road halfway
delusional
um
but also
halfway delusional
fully
winner
your boy won the right tin club this
morning
and we can hit him with a little
we won right ten club this morning
writing them jokes and everybody snoring
reading the other jokes but when they
read mine they like now that's funny
folks
give them the ring give them the meme
everybody looking at him like how does
he be
only b i know is hb hot breath you know
the rest oh
bars
bars let's go yeah
that wasn't that bad actually for being
half
awake right now
like i
if you guys saw me at the right tin club
this morning
is no joke i was
on the end of like a 10-hour drive
but we are here
and every single wednesday at 5 p.m i do
this live q a every wednesday at 10 a.m
i do the live right 10 club
and every tuesday at 5 pm we do hot
breath live where we talk about trending
topics from the perspective of
working comedians
and we also give joke feedback as well
but today my friends
i am here to answer any and all of your
questions we already have some people in
here savannah pin
good to see you my friend
oh savannah oh silvan my apologies my
friend
siobhan silvan i hope i'm saying that
right
they said just found your podcast on
facebook group last week loving it oh
thank you siobhan
and he said bars so
we're onto something special here austin
op as well says love the hat looks good
thank you
it's to hide
um
the fact that i just showered
and it's 5 p.m whatever i've been up
since 5 00 am you're welcome
but i'm here for the next hour to answer
any comedy questions you may have or
just any questions in general about
writing or the podcast or really
i just want to be here for you we're a
community
i just want to be here for you and help
you out however i can
i'm curious siobhan how did you find the
show
and the facebook group how'd you find
all that my friend
i'm gonna pull us up we are live
streaming in our facebook group what's
up nick baskerville
what's poppin fam
good to see you buddy
yeah nick and i did a show
together
this this this this this weekend
this this this this this weekend i've
been on the road basically since last
saturday
got back
today
um and i will say i had to turn in my
rental car late
i'll just say
turning in my rental car late to do the
right tin club
cost more
than the day rate of the car
returning it a few hours late cost me
more than just keeping it for another
day
so
you're welcome for doing the right tin
club this morning and turning in my
rental car late
what's goodie ron jammin
what's goody fam
um savant said i think it was
recommended podcast listen to the good
ones in school of laughs
beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful
yeah those are great podcasts as well
siobhan i love it
i hope i'm saying that right let me know
if i'm not
welcome you to the hot breath verse
what's goodie dc rants we out here
all right
so let's see ron jammin asks
let's see here
let me see
so ron jamming asked thoughts on the
recent chapel attack
well from what i've seen
the attacker got the worst of it um
i'm hoping
this doesn't become a trend for people
thinking they can run on stage i mean
seeing will smith do it at the oscars
was like one level
of like yeah but that's like
an outlier people aren't really gonna
start rushing the stages and then they
rushed one on dave chappelle now
for those of you wondering watching this
as comedians like oh no no one rushes
the stage at that open mic in the middle
of a coffee shop during their lunch rush
i hope i don't get rushed there
if anything you'll get rushed to get off
the stage
um but i will say
i'm hoping
this isn't a sign that people are just
going to
freely start coming up and down on stage
i'm not even sure what
um
what dave was even talking about when
he did get rushed on stage i haven't
seen anything in the context of was he
talking about something
that was provoking
people but whether he was or not that
there's no room for people to be running
on stage so we're going to start
getting
you know some mma training
comedians about enough to become ninjas
up there
uh for self-defense so it's definitely a
crazy situation um something i never
thought
i honestly didn't even think people
would um
start
rushing the stages after that you know i
thought they would just see that was
will smith at the oscars but
dave chappelle the hollywood bowl you
know that's another level but i'm hoping
people are better than we give them
credit for and then they won't start
rushing the stages
but crazy for sure and he got crazy
knocked out he got roughed up so
whatever his idea was for getting on
that stage he regretted it immediately
so he was referencing the dj's i believe
yeah cool so yeah
i guess that's my hot take on the
chappelle attack um
so i just hope it doesn't become the
norm
but you know i've been doing comedy over
12 years
and i've never seen that be an issue but
this is all new
territory for us so hopefully it doesn't
become a trend
but um
time will tell on that one
oh that's hilarious savon said jim
carrey could break out his self-defense
karate seminar from in living color
hilarious
it's true
we're about to have to all need that
it's looking like you know i was a black
belt
i was a black belt back in the disney
you don't get it don't get it twisted
now your boy got it
a little pilsung doe
strip mall karate
i'm a certified black belt
from a karate dojo
that was next to a pizza hut
so
don't mess with me
get a pie in the eye
sorry i heard my wife walking by
and i felt like she could hear me
talking about being a karate kid next to
a pizza hut growing up
um
let's see the next one here
next question
it looks like it's coming from our new
new friend siobhan
um i've read steve martin's book sick in
the head and i'm reading dying up here
are there any other books on stand-up
you'd recommend
um
sounds like you're thinking of like
autobiographical books are you thinking
more of like comedy writing books
because i see dc rants gave a couple
um
mastering stand up from stephen
rosenfield and uh born standing up from
steve martin and judy carter's the
comedy bible savann i don't
want to brag too
i don't want to be too braggadocious
about this but we
on the podcast and i'm about to put a
link
we literally on our podcast just
released and this week was our final
episode actually on this series but we
literally just
released a
um
comedy authors series
where we just released like eight
of our
top interviews with comedy authors like
judy carter
that um dc rants
suggested
and we had steve rosenfield on there
and greg dean
and jerry the joke dr corley i mean we
had them basically every when you go on
amazon and you look up scott dickers
when you look up comedy writing books
all the top authors we had on the
podcast so if you go and look at the
most recent podcasts you'll see
all of them in that author series
so yeah those are good ones
for like comedy writing honestly
i really to keep it a bean y'all mean
i actually made a list
of some good
comedy writing books in my uh amazon
store
i kind of put them all in the same place
and some comedy memoirs memoirs
as well
but if you haven't seen the book i mean
the movie comedian by jerry seinfeld
that's a good one for sure
but i will say here
ah
a link to
a lot of good comedy memoirs for those
of you
looking for those types of books you
know the steve martin was there miss pat
jerry seinfeld
some good ones in there and then also
have a list
of like good comedy writing books as
well
that i will put in here for you to
enjoy there you go my friends you are
very welcome dc
nice
cool so i hope that helps savon
you're already on a good start though
those are some good books to check out
for sure i want to check out sick in the
head i haven't looked at those yet but
they sound very interesting
it sounds like something we could do
with this podcast honestly make these
interviews a book
i mean we've interviewed over 400
comedians there's a lot a lot to share
woo
um next question
oh is that right
that's the question what if it was like
oh is that rain
sick in the head by judd apatow was epic
yeah i heard
uh isn't he releasing another one too
i feel like he was just doing a whole
promo run
we tried to get in on that we haven't
gotten them yet but um
scattered thunderstorms tonight sorry i
was just looking at
i always just thought i heard some
thunder out there sometimes my
um
power can be a bit finicky during storm
so hopefully it won't go out
but
anyway keeping it moving here
how was the book how to kill in comedy
it's it's very popular people have found
it
very helpful i personally
haven't read it
but i know a lot of people that have and
enjoy it
and i did a whole video on like the top
five comedy books as well on the youtube
channel
for those of you interested
all right i see your question there
mudit and this is perfect timing for
this question as i literally
just got off the road this morning
um
so made asked is eating healthy on the
road challenging any tips yes
it is very challenging especially like
you know
i went on like a four day trip
so the biggest way
to make your road trips healthier but
also more cost effective
is to
uh pack your own food so
i know for me
let's just figure out what works for you
but i know for me
especially on long drives you know today
or split up between last night and today
i mean it was a
10-hour drive
so
what i tend to do when i'm driving is i
will eat
just out of like boredom just to kind of
like pass the time
so i i've caught myself
mindlessly eating so many times while
out on the road you're just like driving
and just eating not even thinking
so it can help
what helps me is to pack my own food so
i know i do have a sweet tooth so to try
to help with any of those cravings i
packed my own
granola so i took two things of like
homemade granola so it's still sweet but
it's not you know eating a box of cereal
while driving which i have done before
and by box of cereal i mean the entire
setup like bowl
spoon
cereal
little almond milk you know to keep it
healthy and less depressing when you
catch yourself driving with your knee
while eating because you know eating
cereal i mean that's
that calls all your faculties
so you've gotta you gotta really do a
lot to eating cereal while driving
uh mostly just disappointing your um
family's heritage
but overall
worth it so pack your own food moody
that's really the best way
to eat healthy on the road now i do have
a health expert friend who has been on
the podcast a few times tiara
um she has her own like
health company she's absolutely killing
it
with supplements and
like moisturizers and things like that
that i even that i use
um and she gave some good tips on there
as well of basically like
if you're going to eat something
unhealthy on the road make it the
highest quality version of that as
possible so don't go for the cheapest
most processed version but see if
there's a
a nicer version of that that you you
know if it costs a little bit more
you're going to value it a little bit
more so you you may not just want to
shove it all in your face all at once
you're like well i spent good money on
this i'll eat it in three bites instead
of one
but yeah pack your own food that's the
biggest thing
i can say moody yeah
but
it is challenging you really do have to
make it a priority
and even then it can be difficult
which i can tell you from personal
experience for sure
it can be a bit difficult
nice
oh savon said he's been listening to the
five-minute set episodes nice
well how exciting so good to have you in
the hot breath of earth savon
and thank y'all all for hanging out here
see i saw another question on facebook
this is from kyle jacobson
man y'all just getting the goods out
here shawty yeah i mean y'all getting
all the goodies in the hoodies
um kyle jacobson how many people do you
think is the right amount of people for
a sketch comedy group does it matter as
long as everyone is funny and works well
together
great question um i'm not yawning at
your question i promise
i'm just yawning
after being up since five i basically
woke up drove
pulled over
did the right tank club this morning
and then drove some more
and then took a nap
and here we are
so i appreciate y'all for hanging out
savon's new to the the channel and he's
like oh is this what goes on
i'm usually more
jovial and energetic but i'm i'm tired
i'm tired y'all
but i'm here because i love you
um
and so my wife doesn't make me clean
um no that's not true
so how many people's right amount for a
sketch comedy group i mean
the right amount is what's gonna
be the most fun you know what i mean i
mean
it's tough for me to say from personal
experience because i've never been in a
sketch writing group i have friends who
are in improv groups and sketch writing
groups which gosh i seen the smallest
two people i've seen like an ensemble of
like six so it's kind of personal
preference there but you just wanna make
sure it's with people
that you enjoy
that
uh inspire you that maybe challenge you
but most of all that you have fun with
because
with anything you do in this comedy game
it's gonna be more work than you expect
and if you're in a sketch comedy group
you're gonna be doing a lot of
collaborating and a lot of brainstorming
and a lot of writing and refining
so you want to make sure through that
creative process and that writing
process that does require a lot of trial
and error a lot of ideas
shared but not used
and making sure you're in a fun
supportive group that doesn't make you
feel less than
but um actually just makes the whole
creative process fun
because
it's a lot of work either way so you
just want to make sure you're with
people that you actually enjoy
and that y'all are all working towards
something together you know you want to
make sure and that's something even with
comics at open mics and stuff is a big
thing people
will
do
[Music]
is not think about like who they
surround themselves with so if you're at
open mics
and you're just around the other people
there that are there just to get drunk
or to get high or just bum a cigarette
and you see them at open mics and
they're not really
challenging themselves they're kind of
doing the same jokes over and over again
not trying to rework them not adding new
tags not reworking punch lines or setups
but they're just kind of going through
the motions and they're just kind of
there hanging out and if that's what you
want to do go for it but if you want to
continue to progress and excel and
develop as a comedian you want to
surround yourself with like-minded
comedians so the same thing with your
sketch group just make sure it's with
people who
are motivated and are going to motivate
you and inspire you and challenge you
while also having fun
so yeah
there's no real right or wrong number
there kyle it's just kind of
what works for you my friend
oh my gosh we're getting some questions
and now thank y'all so much for hanging
out here
on live q a day here in the hot breath
the verse
um
next question great question there
though kyle so yeah feel free to comment
with your questions
we're gonna keep the answers coming
ah vodka
oh
i'm dragging bro
y'all are bringing me out of it i'm
feeling good
all right we got some more questions
coming in here tyler good to see you my
friend
ron jammin just asked the question we
got sheehan as well i'm about to get to
y'all's questions
i'm gonna do ron's first cause that's
be the next one i'm seeing in the old uh
yeah
can you explain the difference between a
comedy album and a comedy special well a
comedy album
is just audio only so there's no video
component to it
versus a comedy special you have people
filming it so there's a video aspect to
it
now the pros and cons of each of these
i mean clearly the expense
of video versus just audio
is immensely different it's going to
cost
more
to you know record most likely record a
comedy special versus a comedy album
and honestly something you may want to
do
um when pricing
your production
uh for me personally when i produce my
own comedy special that's available at
joelbuyerscomedy.com if you all haven't
seen it yet
it's called the trophy husband
self-produced it myself but i had a
video guy and then a separate audio guy
because they are
kind of two
different
um specialties now you can do it to
where the video guy does everything but
it's usually
you usually want to keep them separate
because the the biggest pro
of doing a special versus just an album
is just the shareability you know you
can share it
it's easier to share video than like an
audio clip you know and you can post
them on youtube and different social
medias
and for the album you can still
repurpose the album
like by submitting it to siriusxm so you
can monetize it that way as well you
know for me
how i decided to do it for my special is
i didn't release it on youtube i
released some clips on there but i
actually released it on my website
and did it like a by donation button so
people
as an up-and-coming working comedian and
someone who invested in themselves
to
produce their own comedy special and
hoping to inspire others to invest in
themselves and create their own
opportunities
i did it through like a donation base so
when you go to my website you see how to
order the special
and just kind of
donate and whatever it's worth to you
you know so
see people throwing them on youtube all
the time i was just trying something
different to see if i'd be able to
actually make my money back and um it
worked it has worked so i have made my
money back since producing my comedy
special
and uh it's thanks to all of you out
there for checking it out it's super
funny i'm very proud of it excited about
it so if you haven't
joelberrycomedy.com holla at you busy
go check it out y'all
and to make it easier i'll just link it
in the live chat here for those of you
that wanna
check out the special support your boy
and just see a good funny comedy special
um
[Music]
let's see next question thank you ron we
are so close to 20 000 subs
[Music]
answer your comedy questions
and um
tuesdays we're live on here for our hot
breath live show where we do joke
feedback and then
every wednesday at 10 a.m i'm here live
doing our right 10 club where we get a
new word and write a new joke in 10
minutes and give joke feedback and vote
for who wins joker of the day who today
hot off the road
i stopped at a hotel snuck in to their
business center to do the live stream
right 10 club
and end up winning joke of the day so
not too bad fam
cool beans
um so the next one
tyler seymour
and it sounds like it is about the storm
here so if it does randomly shut off
it's because my power went out um
i'm starting open mics
how do you get the audience's attention
if you're performing at a bar or
restaurant and they're too busy eating
and drinking
whoo
yep welcome to comedy um
well i'll tell you the thing you don't
do
you don't berate the audience you don't
heckle the audience you don't yell at
the audience or blame the audience you
know like
keep in mind the context for those
people at the show
so it's like
a lot of times comedy is just thrown
into the middle of a restaurant people
are there like on date nights and having
dinner and all of a sudden there's
open micros with half written ideas that
mostly aren't funny
but they are disruptive to their dinner
so a lot of times i'll see new comics in
those kind of settings like blame the
audience or heckle the audience and such
so
first things first don't do that
make the most of the opportunity make
them feel as welcome as possible
but
sometimes in those settings
you don't get them
but
if you can work towards despite all the
distractions because in those settings
there's probably tvs on every well
everywhere as well and the phone is
ringing
people are walking in front of you to
get to the bathroom you know all those
fun
things of being a famous open mic
comedian
the thing you can do
to really help you develop as a comedian
is
just
performing like it is
like a dope show like everyone is paying
attention
um like you're happy to be there you
know a lot of times especially in
settings like that comics will try to
like phone it in
or you know roast the audience and
things like that or they don't take it
seriously they kind of
drop down to the level of the show
instead of elevating the level to show
to them so you going in treating it like
a real show being authentically
interested and excited to be there
creating a connection with the audience
just welcoming them thanking them for
being there just literally making them
feel
safe to be at this show they didn't know
was going to happen is going to really
go a long way
in um
getting the audience's attention you
know they'll want to listen to people
they like
so if you can be likable they're going
to be more likely to listen to you
but also have the understanding that oh
wow we're just doing kamikaze comedy
here where we just invaded a restaurant
while people were on their date nights
so
it's a balance there
uh but the biggest thing you can do
tyler is just
not phone it in take the show seriously
perform as if everyone is
paying attention to you and loving you
and just
treating the show like a show and not
dropping down to the level of like
roasting the audience or what's wrong
with the audience why aren't they
listening to me things like that
and i say this because these are all
things i've learned the hard way you
know over my 12 years of experience so
i'm hoping to help you avoid some of
those young comic mistakes of
at the end of the day just phoning it in
great question though tyler
um yay
thanks for hanging out everyone this is
so fun
uh so if you do have any other questions
feel free to comment with them
in the live chat here on facebook group
or
on our youtube channel
i'm getting to sheehan's question here
all the way from australia whew
good to see you sheehan
or shahan i hope i saying that right my
friend
from australia we have a lot of hot
breath averse in australia i'd love to
make a trip out there we have a lot of
people in australia
hey what's goodie eclipse lawn care just
stopping by to wave up what's goody fam
we out yeah
what's
we even got the sound effect shawty
what's goodie
nice
so here we go
um you've interviewed some pretty
amazing comedians over the years is
there any
more comics that you're trying to get on
the show that you haven't got on yet any
names you can mention that you'd like to
get on the show
i mean all of them
i want everyone on here i want chappelle
on here i want judd apatow on here i
want jerry seinfeld on here um
yeah i want them all on here
um
so yeah i mean i want all the greats on
here like i want hot breath to be
the premier
comedy interview podcast in the world
and like some
that
um siobhan mentioned earlier you know a
lot of comedy interview podcasts
are hosted by like journalists
so there's not a really in-depth
well-researched
comedy interview podcast
hosted
by a peer
in the industry you know what i mean so
i think that's a big differentiator for
us
but honestly all of them dude
i mean to be completely honest
i'm we ain't aiming for the middle on
this thing but i will say what has been
interesting
um
is that
at the heart of everything we do is
still the community so our most popular
guests aren't necessarily our most
popular episodes you know
the people the hot breath of earth you
us we
enjoy good helpful
genuine content so
some lesser-known people actually will
get more less listens than the more
known people just for the quality of the
content
um or that that guest is speaking to
something more specific than just here's
my experience as a famous comedian you
know so it has been interesting to see
that
really at the heart of everything
is the community
now i'll say all that to say when
people
producing the podcast i mean booking a
guest is a lot of work going back and
forth and scheduling and reaching out
and following up
so it all just
i say i aspire to get all these
comedians um
but it's more of an organic process like
as you say
are there any you're trying to get on
the show like these are all people i
aspire but these aren't people i've like
actively like reached out to or anything
like that
yeah all of them
jim jeffries speaking of australia you
know that would be a good one as well
but great question yeah
oh we got some questions coming in now
good to see y'all in here we got marcus
looks like he just deleted this question
uh where'd you go marcus
godfrey good to see you godfrey let's
see john's question
between lottery mics first come first
serve and slotted mics could you talk
about your opinions on them pros and
cons
and which to do on a given night
lottery mike's first come first serve
and slotted mike's could you talk about
your opinions on them pros and cons and
which to do i mean oh gosh
i'm sorry uh i've been up since 5am i
drove back in
i've been on the road since last week
i just got back in town so i'm
struggling a little bit
but we're still having fun my friends
i appreciate y'all hanging out for this
um
hey john are you talking about like
producing them are you talking about
just like doing them and which ones when
you want to go get stage time which one
to go to
and i'm assuming slotted mic means you
it's like pre-booked or there's an order
already established versus a lottery
where you're just pulling out
names from a bucket i'm assuming
doing them okay cool yeah something
it's really all of them dude i mean
yeah it's it's really all of them at the
end of the day i mean after interviewing
over 400 comedians
and doing comedy
myself
for over 12 years it all comes down to
stage time i can sum it up the number
one piece of advice after 400 interviews
is get on stage that's what all the pros
say you got to get on stage so
regardless of whether it is a lottery
mic or a slotted mic
you got to get up on all of them
you know what i mean i mean at the end
of the day
comedy is a language and you learn it
on stage you know so
yes we do classes and workshops here
uh available at hotbreathmedia.com if
you want to level up your game there
and they'll help you and they'll help
save a lot of the the struggle of
learning how to write jokes and organize
a set or produce your own show
but after you learn all these things you
do need to apply them into practice
whether it is
okay i'm learning how to write funny now
let me translate that to me as a
copywriter or me writing my own blog or
writing my own stand up to them perform
so really
you
you really want to be doing all of them
i came up doing any show anywhere in
front of anyone
um
and he's like with some mics you could
spend all the time waiting but not going
up yeah
i've been there too i've been at shows
where
there's 30 comics
and i go up last
and i paid to be there and after every
comic performs they didn't leave so by
the end it's literally me and the host
standing there
yeah i've actually done that
when i did a trip to new york a few
years ago
i think it was my first trip to new york
but
at the end of the day
yeah you really got to do them all john
and if you're looking to make the most
of your time out of the show
i mean i would recommend maybe even
starting your own i mean hosting
is the
best way to develop as a comedian faster
you just get better at
stage presence at being more
conversational being more interactive on
stage hosting is such
a valuable tool to have in your comedy
tool belt
but some comedy is yeah
show up at seven
get on the list show starts at 7 38
and you sit there
for hours sometimes that's that's the
side of comedy
for free by the way usually costing you
money actually but
that is a side of comedy
that uh most people don't see
that ugly reality of the grind so
just know you're not alone in that john
all right or anyone else listening to
this
that's part of the comedy grind
it's just
that ugly reality that it's not all
netflix my friend
so i hope that helps you buddy
and i hope if anything it helps to
realize oh you're not alone or you're
not the only one
that doesn't feel like going out and
doing this open mic or sitting through
three hours of bombing comics to get to
your three five minute set
but yeah i recommend all comics start
your own show
um
because it can be a way to get paid but
also hosting is just gonna help you
develop that much faster
but producing your own show is a lot of
work as well
so there's no way to outsmart the work
in any of this
hope that helps there john thanks for
asking buddy
great question
godfrey asked did will smith
make stand-up dangerous hashtag
chappelle attack yeah i don't know
i mean i wanna say
i don't know man it's so fresh like i
just heard about it this afternoon like
i've been up since five and i've been
driving and then i finally got home and
took a little nap so i'm like just
hearing of it a little bit i don't know
all the details
but
i'm hoping
these are
the exception to the norm you know the
oscars and then now this happening with
dave chappelle at the hollywood bowl
i hope hope hope that it's
just two outliers um
i just
most
i mean most people aren't going to
comedy shows to get offended to attack
the stage
the vast vast vast majority and this is
the same thing
when people
have brought up like cancel culture and
comedy or oh
everything's so taboo now you can't talk
about anything but like in the comedy
world it's like
the the majority
everything's cool and copacetic and
there's a lot of great comedy fans that
come out and laugh it's these moments
that get the most shine and get the most
press it's the negative
so i think a lot of things are blown up
whether that be that oh you can't joke
about anything anymore but then you got
the clubs and most people are they're
comedy fans they come there to laugh you
know so
i don't see this becoming an issue
um i think it's just a few ex just
circumstances someone wanted to attack
dave chappelle i don't think we're gonna
start seeing
hope that we're not gonna start seeing
you know more and more comics get
attacked on stage
um and hopefully
uh that after photo of the person that
ran on that stage will be a good shot
across the bow to anyone thinking about
charging the stage because he got beat
up bruh
see i don't think so
great question though there godfrey
uh marcus
david what's goody marcus
i need advice on kind of getting away
from just doing only written material
being able to riff and do crowd work or
do you think it's okay to mainly do
written material
i do rip sometimes i'm just nervous my
adhd will make me try to riff about
something between jokes and forgetting
where i'm at on stage
my problem right now is having a lot of
material not being able to perform so
much
so my deal right now is organizing a set
of jokes to do for that day
[Music]
it's honestly
personal preference
for whether or not you want to riff on
stage now as someone for me personally
that does riff on stage
it started
um as me doing like one-liners like when
i started my set list was a script and i
would write it out long hand
word for word verbatim what i wanted to
say at the beginning all the way to the
end and it was like a script
it was a lot of one-liners and over time
i started to develop more confidence on
stage more confidence in my writing and
started to expand beyond one-liners and
start riffing and such on stage but
through that process
yeah there will be times when you do
riff and then get way too far out and
then like lose yourself and then forget
how to get back i've been there before
several times
um but the thing with comedy is that
it's like so incremental
everything you're going to develop as a
comedian you're writing you're
performing your business
it's all going to come incrementally so
it's like you'll see the clips on
youtube and listen to the podcast you
have these aha moments
but it's just like it's one step closer
to achieving your big vision your big
goal let's just get you there one step
there's not gonna be one
thing one idea
one lesson you learned that then unlocks
the world it's just kind of you learn
these little skills and tips and tricks
along the way
apply them to your own comedy test them
out on stage
and just keep what works
so
if you want to riff more
how i started riffing more in the early
days was it was
i would try like a riff i would open up
with like
something improvised
um i remember doing
shows at a a bar called spuds that sold
nothing but baked potato dishes
and the show was in the middle of the
dance floor and they had the disco ball
on and all the disco lights still while
we're doing comedy
remember i went in there and was like
i'm just gonna riff i'm gonna open up
with something improvised and i like
said something about the disco ball and
then went into my set and then the next
week i went there and said something
about the disco ball
and maybe the the um funny sign out
front
okay and i started to build my riffing
that way
um and just
really just set by set
start to slowly develop
that riffing muscle
but it starts with awareness of what you
want to do and then start working
towards it so
i hope that helps you there marcus
but yes
you will do parts where you do riff too
far and then you forget where you are
and you lose your set you maybe have
nothing else to say for the rest of the
time
uh and that's just part of how we learn
my friend
and um
not being able to perform so much so my
deal right now is organizing a set
of jokes to do for that day
yeah you pick your favorite you pick
what you're most excited about
but like we said earlier like the number
one piece of advice is like get on stage
so it requires a lot of stage time a lot
of performing
and recording those performances
and reviewing them and refining the set
that you do so it requires a lot
honestly
to um
just incrementally adjust your set and
develop that material
so
if you don't have
that many performing opportunities you
want to make sure that
you make the most of those that you do
like we talked earlier about the shows
that are at the bars and people aren't
listening
treating those shows
as if it is like a big book show
and actually elevating the show to your
level instead of dropping down to the
show's level is going to help you so
much just in your
mental
fortitude in attacking those shows
but also in just your performance muscle
so that if you can perform in these bad
rooms as if they are good rooms when you
get into the good rooms they become
great and it's just the reward for all
that hard work you've done
so for the shows you do get to do marcus
just
make the most of all those opportunities
be prepared have a set list of your
favorite material you want to do that
night make sure it's rehearsed and make
the most of those opportunities you do
get on stage
but do the jokes that make you happiest
and most excited
because
developing jokes take a long time so you
want to make sure
it's about topics
and experiences and ideas that you
are naturally interested in that do
bring joy to you that are fun a lot of
my favorite jokes started out as
interesting and not funny but i was
interested enough in the idea to find
the funny angle on it so that's a tip
for
you writing and what material to choose
is just make sure you're writing about
things that actually
excite you because there's gonna be
times when you're developing this
material you're like well what's the
point or why bother you know you're
gonna have jokes come and go and
sometimes a joke doesn't work and then
two years later you figure out how to
make it work that's all part of the joke
writing process so
just pick
topics and joke ideas that actually
excite you and that'll help make the
whole
comedy journey that we've been talking
about today that grind
picking topics that excite you is going
to help that entire grind be more
exciting
we dropping bars today bruh
we drop in bars today
yo yo what's up cousin gazz
you are very welcome margus
good to see you rob b
thank you my friend
oh my gosh look at this
frank just want to say my career has
really improved ever since i started
following you and jerry corley i'm frank
theresa all the way from zimbabwe
hey
let's go
thank you so much frank welcome to the
hot breath verse my friend
dang i love hearing that comics help in
comics my friend
all the way from zimbabwe
yo how breath is out here we on every
continent but antarctica so far and
we're coming for you antarctica
hmm
i really appreciate you saying that
frank
that's what's up
um
all right let me let me try to get to as
many of these questions as possible
um
let's see steve polger
i'm looking to do my first open mic
so how soon will i get my netflix
special
hilarious well
i've been doing comedy 12 years
so from my experience it's gonna take at
least 12 years
but
that's the thing about anything
in this comedy game is there's no one
way there's your way so i have friends
30 years into the game never been on tv
or whatever i have friends
two years into the game have made late
night appearances so
there's really no one way there's your
way so
who knows when steve but it does all
start
with that first open mic my friend so
you gotta get on stage to get that
netflix special
i have a hallway full of signed cities
from comedians
wow
that's so cool steve the ones
that stay after the show are willing to
meet and leave an impression for
creating a fan base yeah big facts
awesome steve
uh dc throwing a joke out here
of this opening joke that works 75 of
the time the other 25 you can hear lint
falling on a t-shirt
the timing the wording or what i need
advice on how to deliver this punt or
how to deliver this better or punch it
up with a tag this is my opening joke
hi
is the correct word for what i am right
now
hi is the correct word for what i am
right now y'all i'm so high
i spent a considerable amount of time
at the stop sign waiting for the light
to change
cool
so how to make it better deliver it
better i mean
i've heard versions of that joke of like
being so high you're at a stop sign
waiting for it to turn green
things like that you know i've heard
that
premise
taken before so honestly
dc if you're asking me
um
i mean
a different opener
maybe
it's maybe more unique and personal to
you now you being high i do i do think
that is funny hi
is the correct word for what i am right
now
hi
like
i just heard that stoplight
changing stop sign joke several times so
i think the
delivery aspect of it is
maybe not doing it dc rants
but you know savon said that's funny dc
rant so you know this is just one man's
opinion one comedian to another just
trying to challenge you
dc to
keep writing more personal and keep
looking for more personal material
that's unique to you so if i hear a
joke that i've heard before and things
like that i like to help
younger comics realize hey
yes that may work
but what else is there out there
so if you like if you like
smoking weed getting litty dc you know
there's a lot of material around that
topic that you can do that is unique to
you and isn't just one of these stop
sign turning colors joke
ah
so i hope that helps there dc
um
yo cousin gaz i've been on stage three
times and what scares me more than
bombing is forgetting my material like i
did in my first set
yeah for sure
yeah it all comes down to preparation
you know it's like
the more prepared i am the more
confident i am on stage so that
preparation is
like writing out your set list
rehearsing that set list getting to the
show early so you're not feeling rushed
and you're prepared you know all these
things can help
with that process of getting on stage
because it's already hard enough
to perform and go out and get on stage
even if you don't feel like it on a
weekday at a bar where no one's
listening like we talked about earlier
but congrats on getting up three times
that's great gas congratulations my
friend and it's gonna happen
you're gonna forget your material
sometimes there's gonna be things that
happen you know it is it is an
incremental build this comedy thing and
it happens one show at a time
so the most important part is that you
keep getting on stage despite you
forgetting it one time or whatever
it'll happen again you'll survive but
these are the moments on stage that when
you live them you realize they aren't
that bad and it takes away that power
and then you just
grind out that comedy baby
oh savon loving it love the advice make
it personal and unique yeah yeah we
dropping bars siobhan i appreciate you
hanging out my friend
this is so dope shouty this is dope
oh but we're about to land this plane
here we are at the top of the hour
at the end of this q a hour oh it's a
good question though savon asking steve
when he's doing comedy yeah there's a
lot of people in the hopper at the verse
who haven't gotten on stage yet
i really want to be here to help
y'all get on stage
so anything we can do here at hot breath
to help you out you know we're all in
this together
our facebook group is a great place
to um connect with other members of the
community and write jokes daily and get
feedback and inspiration and just be
like your comedy community you know that
facebook group is a nice supportive and
positive place to to be
so if you just search hot breath
on facebook you will find it indubitably
but now
it is time my friends
we must land this plane
go forth with our days
oh that's great thank you so much i
didn't know it was unoriginal because i
do it all the time said dc yeah this is
how we know
i mean i'm just giving you my personal
advice i'm just hearing that before you
know no shade shouting no shade at all
um
thoughts of cell phone or small
notebooks i usually don't but i forget
and then also cousin gazz asked about
um
notes on stage and stuff it
i personally like it it personally
like comedy's a lot about connecting
with the audience so if you're looking
down at your notebook or your phone
you're completely breaking that
connection and kind of ruining that
illusion of comedy and that conversation
you're having
it always annoys me
and it always
just takes me out of it when i see a
comic use it now that being said
like john said here i think that's
totally okay at open mics guys so
it's personal preference it's
distracting to me
i mean i'm gonna be real
it's a little lazy to me it's a little
disrespectful for the audience that's
there
so i don't like to do it
it can annoy me when other comics do it
but that's one comic's opinion another
comic named gerard carmichael shot a
comedy special at the comedy store where
he had a notebook on stage so it's
clearly like we said earlier there's no
one way in this game there's your way so
if that's what you want to do go for it
but
personal preference
i ain't body body
um
[Music]
hey chicken joe clark said thanks for
everything you do
this was goody fam
i love it
look at us look at us coming in here
yeah yeah oh and steve said he does a
lot of public speaking but only stand up
once like 10 years ago nice
yeah yeah yeah
it all starts with one at a time
oh nice
hosting open mic at the local hoping to
do the open mic at helium in portland
oregon this summer nice savon
very cool my friend i'm excited for it
i'm excited to be on this comedy journey
together so yeah anything i can do to
help savon
happy to do it my friend
um
nice yeah chicken jill clark said he
keeps his notes on an index card in his
back pocket just in case yeah and i
always make a set list and i'll have it
in my back pocket but i don't reference
it because the thing about when you do
forget something it's in those moments
where you're really growing as a
comedian because you're uncomfortable
you're in this discomfort that you have
to figure out and survive on stage and
the more you do that the better you get
at that the better you start to recover
and the better you start to
be more natural on stage more
conversational on stage so when you have
those notes it just becomes like a
crutch and a distraction for the
audience in my opinion
but the best way to like not forget for
me is like just that rehearsal
but also understand that if you do
forget on stage just keep talking
and you will eventually
remember what the joke was so if you're
talking about marriage and then you
forget your marriage joke just keep
talking about marriage and your marriage
or whatever
and it will come back around
and it's funny it's scary at first but
then once you have the experience you
realize oh that wasn't so bad
then you could start to develop it more
noise
look at us
all right there we have one more here
john asked would you only
recommend tags if the original punch
worked or move on to the next
yeah personal preference again you know
i always like to tag up a joke you know
if there's one joke i always like to add
a few tags to it if they're there
but sometimes
there is um
just set up punch and that's the whole
joke you know it just kind of depends
it's not it i do believe it's called a
sense of humor because it is a sense it
is like a sixth sense that we have so
trust yours
you know those of you who have seen our
online comedy writing class i'll use
that a lot of like use the false young
padawan like tap into that sixth sense
your comedy
sense of humor and let that be your
guide to whether or not i think there's
some tags here or you know this may just
be better off
as a one-liner
but i will change the amount of tags
based on the crowd reaction john so
if like the first
few aren't working i'm not gonna then go
run off five more on that joke i'll just
keep it moving but in the early days i
did it all because that was all the time
i had so those edits
on the fly based on crowd reactions come
with years of experience it's something
i always aspired to do
but it took me several years on stage to
actually start getting more natural and
comfortable and confident enough to
be able to listen to the audience one
hear what they're saying back to you
informs in terms of laughter or not
and then adjust my set accordingly that
just takes time on stage really
nice
very very cool
oh what's up sam bass good to see you so
i think the best way to reach a comedian
is to rush the stage on them them on
stage yeah that's a
that's been a hot topic today for sure
it's crazy times out there hopefully
it's nothing
doesn't start spilling over into other
shows you know
ricardo good to see you my friend
good to see you back here we are
actually just about to land this plane
i appreciate you all for hanging out oh
my heavens
whew that flew by i'm like delusional
for being up since five but
man we do these q and a's every single
wednesday at 5 p.m i do a live stream
every wednesday at 10 a.m as well where
we write jokes together and give
feedback and then every tuesday at 5 pm
we also do hot breath live where we give
you joke feedback and also discuss
trending topics from the comedian's
perspective
so we're for comics by comics my friends
and um
i appreciate y'all for hanging out today
and being a part of this q a and just
all i ask in return for all this amazing
free content is that you tell
your fellow comedian about us whether
you're at an open mic whether you're in
a writer's group or you're in other
facebook groups and other comedy
communities tell people about hot breath
tell them to come subscribe to the
youtube channel we're almost at 20 000
subscribers we're trying to hit 50 this
year
so tell your fellow comics about this
youtube channel about the facebook group
and uh the podcast and that we out shia
to help each other
but alas it is time for us to move on
with our wednesdays i appreciate y'all
from around the world australia we had
zimbabwe in here
yo we all the way out yeah
so thank y'all so much
uh and at the buzzer here tyler asked
when you do
what do you do when the laugh isn't
where you want it they laugh at the
setup
but not the punchline type deal yeah
each show's so different so there may be
one show you do that joke and they laugh
at the setup and another joke they don't
laugh at any of it another show they
laugh
at
um
the
the the punch line where they're
supposed to so it's like doing the joke
enough
like 10 times
to get a good read on where the joke is
what kind of reactions has us been
getting across several shows you don't
want one show to determine what you do
with your jokes
you want to perform
several times do that joke several times
and figure out what that reaction is
and then figure out how to start
adjusting the joke
to make it funnier or adjust it by just
kicking it to the curb and putting it to
the side and maybe
revisit it later
so yeah
perform the joke several times and start
to get a read on how the audience is
actually reacting to it
nice
all right well let's land this plane my
friends i love y'all so much oh my gosh
seriously thank you all for hanging out
you could be doing anything
but you're spending your valuable time
with me and i really appreciate that
every wednesday we're doing this q a
y'all
so tell your fellow comics come
subscribe to this youtube channel and
we'll see on the other side my friends
[Music]